alexeï navalni l'activiste anti
corruption russe est hospitalisé dans un
état grave
l' annonce a été faite par sa porte
parole sur les réseaux sociaux
il était à bord d'un avion lorsqu'il
s'est senti mal avant de perdre
connaissance il a été placé sous
respiration artificielle
l agence de presse d'état tu as a
confirmé qu'elle excelle à vail n'y
avait été admis à l'unité de soins
intensifs du service de toxicologie aux
urgences de l'hôpital d'omsk en sibérie
selon le porte-parole de l'opposant
politique ils auraient été empoisonnés
la police ne considère pas à ce stade
qu'il s'agisse d'un empoisonnement
intentionnelle ce que confirme pour le
moment le médecin chef adjoint de
l'hôpital qui a accueilli alexeï navalni
il n'est pas du tout certain que son
état était été provoqué par un
empoisonnement
l'empoisonnement naturel est considérée
comme l'une des causes possibles de la
détérioration de son état mais il peut
aussi y avoir un certain nombre
d'affections qui sont apparus de façon
aiguë et qui ont mené aux mêmes aspects
cliniques
nous travaillons sur toutes les
possibilités nous étudions son état
confirmant ce que nous avons constaté
mais je ne peux malheureusement pas vous
donner plus de détails pour le moment